Speaker 1: Alex Jones new attorney did
an impression of Alex Jones himself. Now,
I am not a legal scholar. I am
not a legal expert. I don't know
that this early in the trial, doing an
impression of your own client shows that
you're heading in a good direction. Maybe
later in the trial, the impressions are
appropriate. Check out this wacky video.
Speaker 2: You'll see a video of the
erupting on air. So Upper East Side
assaulted. I kill the children, I
kill them. I went into the school
and a man and man shot each.
Speaker 3: One of them. Yeah, that's right. When
I go out on the street, people say Adam Lanza was
the killer. They think it's.
Speaker 2: Me.
They made a scapegoat of. Alex Jones.
Speaker 1: The lawyer in doing an impression
of Jones, seems to be using that video where Alex
Jones goes nuts to show how much of a victim Jones
actually is here. Now, of course, what his
lawyer was referencing was this completely
insane interview that Jones gave Andrew Callahan
a couple weeks ago. Remember this. Do you feel.
Speaker 2: Responsible for
what happened to the Sandy.
Speaker 1: Hook families?
Speaker 3: Yes, I killed the children. But
beyond that, no. I mean, I went in that school, I
pulled a gun out. I shot every one of them myself.
I mean, I'm guilty. No, no, no. It's just do I
feel responsible that someone on on the play video
games on a bunch of drugs went and killed a bunch
of kids and then the Internet questioned it and I
covered that. No, I don't feel responsible
and I don't apologize anymore. I'm done.
I don't apologize. I killed the kids. Was there
a defendant? No, I killed him. I killed him.
Speaker 1: Anyway, so that's what was being
referenced there. So the trial clearly not off
to a good start. And then here's another
moment from the first day of the trial,
I believe this was the first day Judge
Barbara Bellis sanctions. JONES Because,
yeah, he refused to. Participate in discovery.
This was an issue in the first trial and it was an
issue in the second trial. And here is the judge
saying you're not participating in discovery.
Speaker 4: I'll make the following observation.
This stunningly cavalier attitude with respect to
their discovery obligations is what led to the
default in the first place. The defendants have
consistently engaged in dilatory and obstructive
discovery practices through from the inception
of these cases, right through to the trial. And
finally, I will note there is there is no notice
in this file to this minute of any supplemental
compliance. Producing the Google Analytic
document, which is required by the practice
but part was also required by my clear court
order of September 30, 2021, which apparently
was not followed here. So the motion is denied
for these reasons, and the Court hereby
sanctions the defendants by preventing them
from presenting evidence or argument that they
did not profit from the Sandy Hook coverage.
Speaker 1: There you go. Judge Barbara Bellis
not not pleased with what is going on. So.
Listen. In all likelihood, this will be another
disaster for Alex Jones. But we're not going
to prejudge it. It's just the most likely
outcome. We're going to follow the case.